this is weird to think about i've been
doing this for so long when i started
there were three late night hosts
and i was the new guy yeah now there's
25 hosts and i'm the i thought you died
six years ago guys
but no it's just thrilling uh this is uh
this is our home stretch as i said just
four more shows left on tbs and then our
plan is to re-emerge on hbo max at some
point
and i am very excited about what's next
okay who said ha tis i who said ha
and i will say hi again huh okay
leslie he's been on the show before
leslie my
the path to hbo max shall not be easy
it shall be filled with inconveniences
ranging in severity from minor to
slightly less than medium
ah sounds like like something i can
handle i can read my words
if you leaving this show indeed will be
then avoid ye must these perils for
that doesn't even rhyme it seemed like
it should have
peril the first do not become a game
show host
keep an eye on the length of your
microphone conan for the longer and
skinnier your microphone gets
the more likely it is that you've been
cursed to spend all eternity as a game
show host
survey says beware
well do not worry i am not gonna host a
game show
correct let's move on to this
to peril the second you okay
i'm great avoid the temptation
to do promotional appearances for now
you can say i am conan o'brien
late night legend but soon you could be
saying
i am conan o'brien for south bay
chevrolet's
christmas in july blowout you'll have a
certified pre-owned career
in hell all right
that's never going to happen i'm not
going to be a spokesman for a car
dealership peril
the third
beware the dreaded marshes of reality tv
the botox will rise from the swampy
waters
and drag you in soon you'll be on
television
arguing with someone named kelly about
why you had to sit next to someone else
named
kylie at the big gala and kylie's pissed
that you insulted her boyfriend chaz in
front of her ex-husband
cheese okay wait a minute
that's not even a name and jesus no it
is not a name
all right you're way off script i will
not be doing
i will not be doing
here it says cheese right there
by the way because we're in a theater
the audience is reading along with you
this is [ __ ] i can see their eyes
like oh this
this next one's good
there's no sight lines here
hold on
so anyway which peril are we on now well
this card says
peril the fourth
you retire and are happy
you just relax you spend time with your
family and enjoy their company
okay well that will never happen
i will never retire i will always be on
television for all eternity yes
excellent news excellent
ladies and gentlemen let's all send this
great man off with a toast
repeat after me and what you read on the
card
made the road smile upon your feet
may the sun laugh upon your groin
may the earthquakes you feel be so tiny
that you have to check twitter
to see if there really was an earthquake
and like more than half the time there
was no earthquake and that's
that's a huge relief at first but then
you start thinking to yourselves
am i going insane imagining all these
tiny earthquakes
say it
forget it oh my god forget it it's fine
i'm very touched good good
come on let's wrap it up all right
there's actually a lot more to that
toast but i'll just tell you later
at you know where well you say this
every time the sex party
to the sex party
[Music]
quick shout out it needs to be said uh
over the years we've worked with many
many amazing writers who are also great
uh
live performers andre dubuche is one of
them
you